Once upon a time, there was a stingy man whose name was Ebenezer Scrooge.
No people in the town liked him.
Even beggars never asked him for anything.
But, he didn't care at all.
One Christmas Eve, he was working late in his office with his assistant, Bob.
It was a very cold day but they had only a small fire to save money.
It's so cold.
At that moment, Scrooge's nephew came into the store.
Merry Christmas, Uncle!
Why are you so merry?   You're poor.
Then why are you so miserable? You're rich.
Bah! Humbug!
Uncle, please come to dinner tomorrow for Christmas.
No, I'm busy.
Are you sure?
I said no. Don't bother me and go away!
Well, have a Merry Christmas anyway, Uncle.
His nephew also wished Bob a Merry Christmas and left.
I suppose you want to have tomorrow off, Bob?
Yes, please.
Okay, but you'll have to come in extra early the next day then.
Oh, sure. Thank you. Have a Merry Christmas, sir.
Bob ran home to be with his family on Christmas Eve.
Scrooge had a lonely dinner at an old restaurant that night and went home.
As he was opening the door, the knocker changed into a ghostly face.
It was the face of his dead business partner, Jacob Marley.
He shook his head and walked into the house.
He looked all through his house and saw no ghosts, so he sat down by the fire.
This is strange, but I don't believe in ghosts.
Just then, he heard strange noises and rattling chains coming up the stairs.
Scrooge! Scrooge! Scrooge!
A ghost walked through a wall and came towards him.
Who is it?
I was your partner, Jacob Marley.
What do you want from me?
I want to tell you that you still have a chance to live a happy life.